- All right, let's finish up
with something awesome
I found on social media.
This is what I'm liking.
(rock music)
If you know me at all,
you know that I'm obsessed
with "The Goonies" movie
since I was a kid.
I love it.
Ask me anything about the
movie, I probably know it.
Where was it shot?
Mostly Oregon.
Was it Josh Brolin's first movie?
Yes, it was.
Was that real blood on the treasure map?
Indeed, it was.
I didn't actually know that.
I just read that on the teleprompter.
That's crazy.
And I wanna know that story.
Where did the blood come from?
Who's was it?
Why was it there?
I don't know.
These are questions.
Still though, there's
at least one Goonies fan
who has got me beat, y'all.
This is incredible.
In fact, he just dropped
more than $1.6 million
to buy the actual Goonies
house, which is so cool.
And we have him on the line right now
at the house in Astoria
watching on Fox 12 Oregon.
What's up, Behman?
- Hi Kelly.
(audience clapping)
- I can't believe you own that house.
That's so cool.
So, you say your whole life
is connected to "The Goonies."
How so?
- Well, after watching the movie
and seeing this gang of kids
basically chase One-eyed
Willie's treasure,
it shaped who I am today.
I mean, we used to go as kids
and knock on neighbors houses
and go down to the basement
looking for tunnels.
It was awesome.
And so my whole life,
my businesses and
everything that I've set up
was related to "The Goonies" movie.
I mean, you remember when
they were chasing the treasure
down in the tunnel, they
found a baseball card.
Lou Gehrig baseball card.
I buy and sell baseball cards.
They're chasing golden gems.
I'm in that business as well.
And then how about an escape
room and an ax throwing place?
I mean, this is all
connected to "The Goonies."
- Wait, you own an escape room?
- I have an escape room with four rooms.
I do.
- Oh my God, I love escape rooms.
That's so cool.
Well, how did you end up with this house
and are you living in it?
- Yes, part-time.
I got super lucky.
I mean, we visited about 10 years ago,
and when we were coming
down the neighborhood
we're like are we gonna get
arrested for trespassing?
Is this even okay to visit?
We have no idea.
So, I had that feeling
of wouldn't it be amazing
if we could just walk up
there comfortably and visit?
Sure enough, my wife
and I were able to go up
and visit the house,
and we're like we would
love to own this someday
if that would at all be possible.
But ever since owning it,
we got lucky by simply Sandy knowing
that it was gonna be us that
continued "The Goonies" legacy,
and so she picked us.
Because we want to recreate this movie
or this house to look exactly
like it did in the movie,
including the contraption
in the front yard
where Chunk did the truffle shuffle.
- Yes.
- And the inside of the house as well.
So, we just keep telling
Goonies, you're welcome to visit.
Just be respectful to
the neighbors, you know
just understand it's actually
a neighborhood and whatnot,
but come and visit this iconic house.
You're welcome to come here
and just know that dreams
really do come true.
- Oh my God, I love you Behman.
This is so cool.
I love it.
That's so exciting.
Thank you so much, Behman.
I'm liking your post right now, all right.
(audience clapping)
- [Behman] Hey you guys.
(Kelly laughing)
- Alright, so usually
this would be the time
we give our guest $1,000
courtesy of our season
long partner Pilot Pen,
makers of FriXion, the go-to erasable pen
of "The Kelly Clarkson Show,"
but Behman's clearly done
quite well for himself,
'cause he's got 1.6 million
G's to drop on a house.
So, he's fine.
He found his treasure.
So, today the money's going
to somebody in the audience.
So, the check
(audience clapping)
is actually under
someone's chair right now.
It's taped to your chair.
Who has it?
(drumroll)
(exciting music)
Hello.
What's your name?
Stand up.
- Hey.
- Hi.
- How are you?
- What's your name?
- Ethan.
- Yeah.
- What are you gonna do with a grand?
- I don't know.
Probably go out for dinner.
- All right.
That's a nice dinner, Ethan.
- [Ethan] Yeah.
- Thank you so much.
Hope you have so much fun with it, Ethan.
Thank you to all our guests this hour,
Keri Russell, O'Shea Jackson, Jr.,
Justin Hart, and Brynn Cartelli.
Y'all have a great day
and if it's not, well, try and change it.